girl at a festival nowadays very
revealing clothing yeah so that's that's
probably the trend but when lizzo is
doing it it's getting publicized it's
everywhere it's been pushed by media and
then on top of that she's proclaiming
that she's happy at that weight as well
so she's also leading with that she's
responding to criticism why is she
getting criticism
because the majority of people don't
find that attractive and you go and you
guys can't a lot of people can't do
anything about that to the average
individual they don't find fat people
attracted to you maybe not I'm telling
you as a big person myself I'm not gonna
go out I get a lot of it yeah and I know
a lot of big women that get attention
you're talking about a niche no no no
not me